yesterday i told you that i was going to
do my best to ignore the democrats
january 6th histrionics and instead
focus on the actual feast it was little
christmas the feast of the
epiphany i mostly succeeded at that but
i
i made a slip up
and and now i fear that my face is stuck
in a permanent state
of cringe
i i knew i shouldn't have watched it but
i saw across my computer screen that
nancy pelosi and the democrats
had invited
the cast of hamilton
to their struggle session
to sing them a song about how great they
all are
we are all stewards of the american
experiment
working to pass down to our children and
our grandchildren a more perfect union
that treats all its citizens with
fairness and equity i'm dedicating every
day to you
domestic life was never quite my style
when you smile
you knocked me out i fall apart and i
thought i was so smart
you will come of age with our young
nation
we'll bleed and fight for you
we'll make it right for you
if we lay a strong enough foundation
we'll pass it on to you
we'll give the world to you and you'll
blow us all away
someday
someday
[Music]
what nancy pelosi
and lin-manuel miranda and the rest of
the democrats have done to us
is far far more violent than what any of
the alleged insurrectionists did
last year
on january 6th i'm michael knowles this
the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from vjs who says
just asking for a friend but isn't it
kind of racist to not give blm an
anniversary for any of their riots such
a good point
white supremacy wins again
except it's a little complicated because
some of the alleged white supremacist
insurrectionists were not white at all
there were plenty of black people and
hispanic people at the capitol and
a lot of the blm rioters were extremely
pasty antifa people so it doesn't really
break down quite on
perfectly on racial lines but yes i
agree i think that's a great example
of white supremacy and that's not good
for our future when you want to plan for
your future i would strongly recommend
you check out alto ira do you have an
account with coinbase are you thinking
of opening one are you crypto curious
i am i hadn't really been that
interested in crypto and then recently
i've just completely gotten into it with
the nfts and the the ethereum and the
meme coins and all this stuff well
crypto may very well represent the
future of money it's certainly a very
important new technology and so
everyone's really getting involved and
they're getting investing in it and
trading it and like so many things in
life there's a smart way to do it and a
dumb way to do it the really smart way
to do it is to go check out alto ira so
that you can invest in bitcoin ethereum
cardano in a tax advantaged ira super
easy to set up you can invest with as
little as 10 bucks no setup charges this
is industry leading security
the advanced encryption standard for
wallets and private keys multiple ways
to fund your account you do it with cash
cash contribution transfer cash from an
existing ira roll over an old 401k are
you ready to take your investments to
the next level diversify like the pros
and trade without tax headaches open an
alto crypto ira with as little as 10
bucks go to altoira.com
michael that's a-l-t-o-i-r-a-dot-com
m-i-c-h-a-e-l start investing in crypto
today alto ira.com michael
i said yesterday that i was going to
ignore the democrats histrionics and i
did i really i didn't watch joe biden's
stupid speech i assume it's stupid i was
told it was a very stupid speech i
didn't watch it i didn't watch msnbc and
cnn and all of the histrionics instead i
enjoyed the feast of the epiphany it was
it was lovely the reason that i didn't
pay attention to the dems histrionics is
because
the capital riot such as it was
is not a significant event in itself
it's not it did it's not even the most
significant insurrection of the year
leading up to it
that would have been blm and antifa
killing dozens of people attacking
federal buildings looting rioting
burning down and pillaging at different
cities
however
the reason i mention
lin-manuel miranda and nancy pelosi and
all the rest of them is
because
january 6th could be
an extremely historically important
event
as a myth
not in what happened what happened at
the capitol really doesn't matter at all
there was there was one person killed in
the violence of that day and it was one
of the alleged insurrectionists being
killed by a trigger-happy cop right so
what the what the rioters did that that
doesn't really matter but the mythology
that is coming out of this that that
really could matter okay the myth is why
nancy pelosi hired broadway performers
to come down and dramatize the whole
incident if the event itself were
sufficiently dramatic
to to
warrant some place of significance in
american history then you would just
have a report from the january 6th
committee and you would just have them
recount the events and you would talk
about all the police officers who were
killed and all of the the
government that was overturned and you
would talk about it except none of that
happened so they can't talk about it so
they have to invite actual actors to
come down and and dramatize the event
and sing a song
explicitly about how great nancy pelosi
and the rest of the democrats are that's
the whole song and you'll blow us all
away you're going to shape our country
lin-manuel miranda says it at the
beginning he says you're doing you're
standing up and we need to stand with
you and you're so great and you're so
wonderful and then you have all these
geriatric dem mostly geriatric democrats
you're saying yes we are good
our legacy is good and they're smart and
they're smart and they're doing a really
really good job of this
because
myth
matters in politics myth matters in
politics and statecraft
often more than history does
the myth is much more important kamala
harris
came out
she compared
the capitol riot last year to
not just
pearl harbor but september 11th as well
good morning
certain dates echo throughout history
including dates
that instantly
remind all who have lived through them
where they were
and what they were doing
when our democracy came under assault
dates that occupy
not only a place on our calendars
but a place
in our collective memory
december 7th 1941
september 11
2001
and january 6
2021
on that day
i was not only vice president-elect
i was also a united states senator
this comparison
is deeply offensive you know some of us
knew people who died on september 11th
okay some it wasn't that long ago a lot
of people remembered especially people
around new york especially those who
were millennials or older might remember
this to compare 3 000 americans being
killed in a terrorist attack to the horn
guy dancing around the capital rotunda
is really disgusting and is genuinely
extremely offensive but it's got a point
it's got a political point
january 6th
is a myth it is completely made up if if
not completely made up it's 99 made up
it's based on an actual riot that took
place at the capitol but virtually
everything you've been told about it is
a lie and has been turned
proven to be a lie and even some
newspapers had to retract it though no
one was paying any attention to the
retraction so the lies persist
all countries have myths how was rome
founded
rome you know rome the roman republic
becomes the roman empire how was it
founded
there are two stories about how rome was
founded
one is that it was founded by aeneas
right like the aeneid like the the
poem by virgil it was founded after the
trojan war and the other is romulus and
remus and these are related myths but it
was founded by romulus and remus these
two boys who were who were fed and
raised by a she-wolf and then they they
form the civilization and romulus kills
remus i'm simplifying a little bit but
those are the stories did that happen in
real life ah probably not but
that's the myth and the myth is the
identity of rome
it's much more important than whatever
council met and wrote some document
together and took the many many steps
that very slowly created what became
wrong
no romulus and remus that matters a
whole lot more
nash even even modern countries like our
own country have national myths and some
are true and some are not true
george washington
what's his relationship to a cherry tree
every school boy knows this or at least
used to know this when we taught the
american myth that george washington
chopped down a cherry tree but he could
not tell a lie so he admitted that he
chopped down the cherry tree did this
happen no but it's part of the myth of
america and it and it forms a lot of our
identity and it forms our understanding
of our past and our forebears and who we
are ourselves january 6th
with all the scare music and all the
hyperventilating and all the pearl
clutching that is now
part of the american myth the democrats
are desperate to establish that one and
so they're going to have festivals every
year and they're going to have big
speeches and they're going to have
big solemn celebrations they're probably
going to erect a statue they're going to
have broadway performers do songs and
dances to it
lies shape history
just as much as the truth very often
there's a ucla professor
named kara cooney she's an egyptologist
and a social historian who focuses on
gender
theory and gender studies so you know
she's going to be a real treat
this ucla professor just published a
book
about egypt
that for whatever reason
wrote
or included a passage about kyle
rittenhouse
kyle rittenhouse the kid who was getting
chased by the antifa guys in kenosha
wisconsin and shot them and
what she says about kyle rittenhouse is
that kyle rittenhouse
you quote used his semi-automatic weapon
to kill two black men
in kenosha wisconsin while waging a
glorious race war on behalf of his
inherited white power
this isn't a book about egypt and it's
just not true it's not the people that
that kyle rittenhouse killed were not
black they were white guys they were
extremely pasty white guys
and and kyle rittenhouse was not waging
a race war and there's no evidence of
that whatsoever it's completely made up
but if you went and asked people on the
street right now hey
what happened in kenosha wisconsin i bet
if they'd heard of it at all i bet you
99 out of 100 would say oh some white
supremacist kid killed some black people
that's what you would hear
and in part that's because these myths
are being pushed
by
very influential people by our educators
even educators at very prestigious
universities now when you want to help
save the country
not just the cultural aspects of the
country but the financial aspects your
own dollar you know charity starts at
home what do you got to check out you
got to check out get upside if you are
not currently using get upside you are a
dummy i don't know how else to put it
okay get upside is free
money at the tank at a time when gas is
going through the roof how does it work
you sign up with the free get upside app
in the app store or google play right
now use the promo code knowles know wles
you will get 25 cents cash back
for each gallon of gas that you buy
you're probably thinking michael that's
not true i'll tell you what it's
actually not true it's not true because
on your first fill up you will get 50
cents cash back per gallon
this is an unbelievable opportunity it's
a wonderful app it's free to download
get upside right now there's no catch
just cash back you can get that cash
back directly into your bank account or
with paypal or with an amazon gift card
or some other gift cards
super easy really great time especially
after the holidays when we've all spent
all of our money head on over get upside
right now use promo code knowles get up
to 50 cents per gallon cash back on your
first tank that is code knowles
this ucla professor kara cooney who
published a book on egypt and it
completely lied about kyle rittenhouse
why she was talking about kyle written
now is no one knows but she she said
that kyle rittenhouse killed these black
people and he was
raging a race war on behalf of white
power
she got called out on this
someone found the book somehow i assume
it's just because she assigned it to her
students no one reads these obscure
academic books that the professors
published just to maintain their own
jobs but someone found it and so she
tweets that quote on page 341 of the
good kings i state the kyle rittenhouse
shot two black men when instead he shot
two white men that was my mistake and i
apologize the response has been a
hateful stew of ridicule and denial that
america has a race problem at all if one
mistake in a little-known book about
ancient egypt elicits this much howling
it is to avoid discussing our larger
problem to avoid seeing our deep-seated
obsession with patriarchal power
first thing i noticed here
is this woman who is a professor at a
prestigious university who is apparently
such a sloppy historian that she doesn't
check basic facts of events that she's
writing about events that have nothing
to do with the ostensible subject of her
book i noticed that she doesn't know how
to spell deep-seated
it's deep seated like you're sitting
down in a chair like seated but she
wrote seated like johnny appleseed like
you're going out into your garden
which is i guess it's a minor point
but it reveals a greater problem
which is that our academics the people
who are teaching our kids
today even at expensive fancy schools
are not
particularly bright or well educated
that's a side point
though it does speak to the bigger
problem here she gets caught she
published this total lie she gets called
out on and she smears this young man
she gets called out on and she says look
yeah okay that part was false
but it gets to a greater truth
yes no it's true there wasn't a white
supremacist kid shooting black guys to
wage a race war in kenosha but it gets
to the greater truth of our awful white
supremacist country and the race war
that's being waged
no it doesn't
it's just a lie
it's a lie you peddled a narrative and
it was false and you got called out on
it you don't want to admit that you were
wrong
lies do not get to greater truths the
libs do this every time you call them on
their bs
they say well okay so that yeah that
turned out not to be true but it gets to
a greater truth no it doesn't it's just
lies and
and there are a lot more lies even than
you get called out on does anyone really
believe right now in the year of our
lord 2022 in the united states that
america has a pervasive problem of white
supremacy
that that the
prevailing culture is one in which it is
encouraged to insult and attack black
people
and and to
exalt white people is that really the
racial culture we're living in right now
last time i checked white people
are the only group that you're allowed
to legally discriminate against that's
not true there's the exception of asians
you're also allowed to discriminate
against asians in certain instances but
mostly it's white people you can
discriminate against them in
college admissions you can discriminate
against them in employment
beyond the law if you just look at the
you can discriminate against them in
certain grants and certain certain uh
funding but beyond that even just in
terms of the culture the only group the
only racial group that you're allowed to
and encouraged to
insult are is white people
and it's commonplace to insult white
people and talk about how awful white
people are and how they've caused all
sorts of problems if you ever insulted
black people or hispanic people or age
even asian people who are in this
strange category where they can be
legally discriminated against but if you
insulted them in the culture you would
be ostracized you would be booted out of
polite society you would be you would be
censored and a lot of people are so it's
just not true the the greater truth that
she's talking about is just a complete
lie as are the things that she's stating
when we're talking about racial politics
one of the clearest examples of this
today
in public life is joy reid joy reid on
msnbc
joy reid was discussing the january 6th
myth and she like everyone else in the
liberal establishment was trying to
firmly establish this as part of the
american mythology and she said that joe
biden is going to address january 6th
and
he is getting a ton of hate from
republicans and she's so shocked by this
because it seems that joe biden's
getting just about as much hate as
barack obama
so tomorrow president biden is going to
speak and there's a question of whether
or not he actually
can
change this or he can he can alter it at
all because
unbelievably he has become
for republicans as much of a
sort of figure of hatred a hate object
as president obama was you know the
black president like i mean he was his
vice president maybe that's part of it i
don't know what it is but this is like
the most sort of norm core democrat ever
it's so strange it doesn't make any
sense
joe biden's getting as much hate as
barack obama but those republicans only
hated obama because he's black and yet
they hate joe biden just as much
i guess it's got to be because joe
biden's kind of black that's that's her
conclusion effectively i'm only slightly
exaggerating
she's saying that
republican it doesn't make any sense
that republicans would be just as hard
on this democrat president as they were
on the last democrat president because
her premise is that they only hated the
last democrat president
not because of his political views or
all the terrible things he did but
because of the color of his skin so the
only way
to resolve this tension
there are two ways she could either
recognize that republicans did not hate
obama because he was black they didn't
like barack obama because he was a jerk
and a terrible president did all sorts
of horrible things
or she could conclude that joe biden is
somehow kind of black
or is associated joe biden who's a very
white guy is somehow kind of sort of
black
when reality runs contrary to the racial
narrative her answer is to change
reality
that joe biden is a black guy and and
not to put too fine a point on it but
it's not just that republicans don't
like biden as much as they didn't like
obama
they seem to like him considerably less
than they liked obama there's a new poll
out from civics
a job approval poll shows that biden's
job approval rating which was already
extremely low is it 38 or 37 it's now
dropped down to 35 percent this is just
after biden received a record high
disapproval rating of 56
really really bad stuff
biden's
net approval rating right now is
negative 20.
really bad news for biden especially
heading into the midterms then looking
ahead to 2024. this is why you are
getting
all the january 6 stuff i guarantee you
if joe biden were popular right now if
the democrats had anything that they
could run on anything they don't have a
single thing they're below water on
every single issue
if they had anything they could run on
you'd probably get some histrionics
about january 6 but you wouldn't get
nearly as much they wouldn't be so
desperate to enshrine that in the
national mythology but because they got
nothing
they need to use january 6 and it's one
for this cultural reason of establishing
republicans as terrorists in people's
minds but it's also for a very practical
reason they're pushing for a federal
takeover of elections
republicans are calling this bill that
they're pushing the corrupt politicians
act it was the first bill that they took
up in the new house of representatives
and in the senate when the democrats
took control
because they know that if while they now
have unified government and they control
the whole thing if they can take power
to govern elections away from the states
away from local governments give it to
themselves take away all of the
safeguards that prevented them from or
impeded them from stealing elections and
enshrine their new rules
no voter id widespread unsolicited
mail-ins election day turns into
election month all that kind of stuff if
they can enshrine that then they believe
that they're going to give themselves a
permanent electoral majority so it all
ties in together there's the really
abstract stuff about the national mythos
but there's also the really practical
stuff they want to pass this law
why do they want to do it because
according to the democrats according to
pete buttige
everyone's favorite transportation
secretary
democracy is sacred
democracy that's what he tweeted out on
january 6th democracy in his super duper
glib
pete butter judge
harvard educated worked at mckinsey just
the most glad-handing shallow individual
you've ever met in his in that tone you
can hear it
democracy is sacred
democracy is not sacred
democracy is not sacred and
peat buddha judge and the democrats
are some of the least likely people to
believe democracy is sacred that's why
they're upending so many of the
safeguards to protect our democracy on
the election integrity laws
and also in terms of how laws are passed
and how our government works they're
trying to take a lot of power away from
the people and away from the states and
give it to unelected bureaucrats if they
could
crown dr fauci as the emperor of the
country indefinitely right now they
would do it they effectively have done
that so i don't want to hear anything
about democracy from these people they
don't like it very much the
conservatives are far greater defenders
of democracy and furthermore democracy
is not in itself sacred democracy is a
nice form of government we like
democracy
but there are other forms of government
that can be good too
this is what is described by the
ancients as the cycle of regimes
there are
according to this theory three good
forms of government and three bad forms
of government and they relate to one
another democracy can be great
but democracy can be really bad too we
call that mob rule the founding fathers
were very afraid of it
aristocracy can be great there have been
good aristocracies in the history of our
civilization
but aristocracy can be really bad that's
when it becomes oligarchy that's
increasingly what our own government
looks like
monarchies can be great there have been
great monarchies in the history of the
west some of the greatest governments
in the history of the west have been
monarchies
the kingdom of god is not a democracy
it's a it's a monarchy
but there can be a bad version of
monarchies which is tyranny that's when
you have some tin pot dictator
there are good versions and bad versions
and what the the libs are trying to
convince us all of now
is that we're living under some
shining perfect democracy and they're
going to take us even further in that
direction they're not
we are living practically under an
oligarchy and they are taking us much
further in that direction and they're
trying to pass laws at this very second
that are going to make our government
more oligarchical more easily controlled
by a small group of people who are in
government who are in private business
who are working in the media and they're
all working in cahoots with one another
to keep the people down it's as simple
as that
just when you think
that the democrats in office actual
mainstream democrats
cannot get more
transparently hypocritical they do
something like this
in the liturgical season of january 6
where they're trying to convince us that
republicans are traitors and
insurrectionists and they're trying to
overturn our government and and they're
evil people who need to be ostracized
from society and they hate their fellow
men
a democrat city council member in
portland maine
has just been found selling a sticker at
one of his businesses that says abort
republicans
abort he's selling other stickers too
he's selling a sticker that says defund
god
lowercase g too uh thank you for making
me a godless hoe and are we [ __ ] this
is at at his
at his uh coffee shop
this was reported first by the
post-millennial
it shows you where the real power is
it goes without saying if a republican
did anything like this if we had
stickers that we were selling saying
kill democrats we would be arrested we'd
be thrown in guantanamo bay we'd
probably be
in the
solitary confinement cell right next to
the horn guy and right next to the dad
who was popping a coors light in the
capital rotunda during that that most
world historic day in the history of our
nation
shows you where the real power is the
power is almost entirely with democrats
democrats working in cahoots with the
liberal establishment the media the
universities the woke corporations the
big technology they control basically
everything
and what they will do is project and the
things that they are doing themselves
they will accuse us of doing
they do this on racial matters they do
this on sexual matters they do this on
matters of politics and government where
is the power really lie where is that
where the real threats to democracy
speaking of excuses got to get to this
eric swalwell
our favorite
eric the man who is nearly president
congressman eric swalwell
who is best known for
uh having a
bodily function on
television news and for sleeping with a
chinese spy eric swalwell has been
really tough on conservatives for not
following the public health orders and
listening to dr fauci and going along
with with the kovid mania he tweeted out
quote as we end 2021 this was just a
week or so ago as we end 2021 mired in a
deadly pandemic you should know who has
prolonged it these guys republican liars
your vacation canceled your kids back to
virtual learning and back to masks
everywhere for blame look no further
than these guys talking about
republicans and then what happens what
happens we
catch alex eric swalwell without
a mask on he was down in florida
he was not wearing a mask
we've done this a billion times we've
caught all of these democrats fauci
himself maxine waters pelosi warren the
mayor of san francisco aoc we caught all
these people not wearing masks when
they're telling all the rest of us to
wear masks and so a photographer got a
picture of it published it and swalwell
responds and he doesn't say i'm sorry oh
you no actually i i didn't mean to it
was a one moment no he
he tweets out quote they got me
maskless juggling a baby and a coffee
while meeting with a congolese queen
pulitzer please he's making fun of the
journalists he's saying they deserve a
pulitzer
i can't tell by the phrase congolese
queen if he
means that he's meeting actually with
the congolese queen or if he's just
using it in the modern sense of the word
like this is just a congolese woman he's
sort of yes queen
i don't know i don't know which one
would be funnier either way
swalwell got caught in the hypocrisy
and
he's unrepentant
he's shameless about it
he's not he doesn't even
practice the hypocrisy which is what the
tribute that vice pays to virtue he's
not even saying oh no actually you're
misunderstanding you don't get it
no he's saying no there's one set of
rules for me there's one set of rules
for you look i had good intentions and
so we're going to judge me and we're
going to judge my friends the democrats
by our intentions and we're going to
judge you republicans by your actions
and the worst way that i could possibly
depict your actions
it's whatever swalwell or or pelosi or
biden or kamala or fauci or any of the
rest of them whatever they want to do is
fine as long as they've got a good
reason as long as they have a good
excuse and whatever you want to do is
not fine
because you have to submit to their
whim speaking of different standards
there's a story out of yale
yale university i'm really sorry to say
at the forefront
of
wokeness and the destruction of the
american university and other elite
institutions yale has now announced that
students can return to campus anytime
between january 14th and february 4th
but they must quarantine in their
residences except to pick up food and to
take covet tests constantly
and
maybe to take academic tests no i assume
that's online too until they receive the
results
of an arrival test
yale has instituted this campus wide
quarantine until february 7th
and the students may not visit new haven
businesses or eat at local restaurants
even outdoors
they can maybe go for curbside pickup
but they can't
really participate at all in the
community they've got to lock up in
their dorm rooms
what this is about is not just idiocy is
not just an overreaction it's not just
an unscientific policy it's about a
consolidation of power i have a personal
connection to this story because i
once quarantined at yale when i was an
undergraduate i had the swine flu that
was the that was the big problem that
was going around the country then and so
i think it was the swine flu whatever
the big flu was that year i got it they
made me quarantine
what did that mean it meant i was
supposed to stay in my room
but that's not what kids do at college
you know what kids do at college they do
a lot of bad things they shouldn't be
doing
okay and especially at that campus by
the way
what do you think is going to happen you
get kids who have covet and they're
going to go into their
college dorms their co-ed college dorms
on one of the busiest campuses in the
entire country and they're what are
they're just gonna sit quietly in their
rooms
do you think that's what's gonna no i
think they're gonna spread
covet and maybe a few other illnesses as
well okay
so what's the point of this
the point is the separation
the point is that these elite yale
students
they can't go and pick up the nasty
germs at the local new haven shops they
might meet some townsfolk
would you imagine get their filthy
disgusting peasant germs on them that
wouldn't be good no we've all got to
stay separate and we're going to stay in
our corner you're going to stay in your
corner and we're all just going to order
amazon and we're all just going to live
in the metaverse and we're all just
going to keep to ourselves and live in
our own little chambers and and what
we once considered civil society
what we want once considered to be our
real politics which is you go out and
you see people and you engage in the
community that's going away and one of
the reasons that's going away i know
this sounds crazy and kooky and
conspiratorial but
if if you don't think that there is a
major political power grab going on
after the last two years i don't know
how to help you what is happening here
is that
the few remaining impediments to a
consolidation of the power of the
liberal establishment are being
demolished and that is small businesses
and that is
local communities and that is families
these things are being demolished and
you can you can quantify it it's
happening in real time and it's no
coincidence that the elite institutions
are at the head of it
today's a really big day
today is a really big day because
the daily wire is suing the biden
administration
the supreme court
has convened to hear oral arguments in
this case
about the constitutionality and the
legality of joe biden's mass mandate
we've already got over a million
signatures on our do not comply petition
keep signing keep signing we need to
send a message the court reads public
opinion
the court reads the polls sign up
add your name send it to your friends
dailywire.com
do not comply
we'll be right back with the mailbag
welcome back to the mailbag so good so
good to be with all of you my favorite
time of the week first question up from
sarah hey short question today what do
you think will happen to the horn guy
and other people who the left wants to
burn at the january 6th stake i think
they're going to have the book thrown at
them that's already happening some have
been held in solitary confinement some
have been held in really terrible
conditions and if i were
president right now
if i were in any position of power to
help these people i would
i would
consider pardoning them outright i would
commute a lot of their sentences and if
i were
in some position to
deal with the details of the prosecution
i would seriously diminish the charges
against them
obviously it would be on a case-by-case
basis you'd have to see what people were
doing but i would i would dramatically
reduce the charges against them why
would i do that is it because i'm soft
on crime now is it because i merely want
to reward my friends and punish my
enemies no it's because what happened to
them is deeply unfair
the blm terrorists who actually killed
people the blm terrorists who burned the
country down for eight months and
attacked federal buildings an assault on
our democracy and who looted and robbed
and pillaged and burned
those guys largely got off the hook when
you look specifically at the bronx and
manhattan
the vast majority of them just had their
cases dismissed or pled down basically
to nothing and so we cannot live in a
country where the left
gets off the hook for very egregious
violence and the right has the book
thrown at them and they rot in a jail
cell for relatively minor infractions we
can't live in that country
now you might say well it would be
better if both of them were punished a
lot okay yeah maybe it would okay maybe
i guess i don't know what i do know is
that the left has already been led off
the hook and so as a matter of justice
not just as a matter of good politics
but as a matter of justice i would
i would i would let the horn guy out of
his cell if he's still there i don't
know that he's still there but i would i
would dramatically
reduce the the charges against against
the alleged insurrectionists when i
wouldn't
when i wouldn't just
let them off the hook entirely and then
the left can learn their lesson and then
maybe the left will stop going so light
on the crime when their own guys commit
it and then maybe we can return to some
normal semblance of government
but we're not going to get back to good
government
by letting the left get away with murder
literally murder in some cases and
throwing the book at the conservatives
from quentin hey michael i have a
question this might be dumb what is the
christian view on anime girl pillows
huh
hypothetically speaking if one were to
use it as a sleep aid like for sleep
who would that be wrong
on one hand it's a pillow so it should
not be a problem on the other hand there
is an anime girl on it so it might be
considered wrong keep in mind this is
only hypothetical
i'm going to do something i usually
don't have a computer in front of me but
we were snowed home over the past few
days so i usually keep note cards i
don't like having screens in front of me
during the show but i do have a computer
which means that i'm holding i'm going
to put on my like
my expressvpn right now i can't i don't
want to have this typed into my google
history anime girl
pillow
what is an anime
okay well that makes sense it's just a
pillow of an anime girl but they're long
it's like a full body pillow okay well
if if you have this pillow
quentin because you just really like the
artwork and you just really appreciate
the art and the beauty of the anime girl
pillow
i guess that's fine
a little weird but fine
if you have this
full lady-sized cartoon lady pillow that
you hold in your sleep
for some less wholesome reason
that would not be fine that would be
probably a near occasion of sin
and appeal to the prurient interest and
throw out the pillow buddy don't that's
don't have the pillow that's
i've okay i'm i'm not gonna be i'm
changed my mind just no just no no
pillows none of that sarah
dear michael how do you find happiness
oh just that little question happiness
is not a guarantee in this life but i
believe that you can always find it
regardless of the circumstances in your
life
what advice do you have to find
happiness when you're you're feeling
anything but i actually do have a direct
answer to this
which is and the
ain't the ancients who we keep invoking
those ancient greeks have an answer to
which is that
we want to order our life toward
happiness for true happiness
toward the life well lived which is not
merely subjective and about our own
personal preferences and tastes but is
an objective standard there are good
things that you can do there is such a
thing as
virtue for instance and excellence and
the way we attain that is by practicing
the virtues which is not merely moral
it's not just do good things and and and
avoid committing sins but it it has
other aspects to it it means excellence
more broadly
so it would be working out something
that i don't do very much but that would
that would be one way to be happier is
if you if you treat your body well and
you eat healthy foods and you do good
things it would be to attain wisdom that
will make you happier it will be to
cultivate your courage that would be
something that would make you happier
and it would be to practice the virtues
and do good and avoid evil that will
make you happier now bad things will
still happen to you
which is why the
pure cultivation of virtue is not going
to be sufficient in the end it's why you
need to know your god because any
understanding of what is good that is
divorced from god is not going to make a
lot of sense and it's not going to be
satisfying so
it's
very helpful to know that even as you're
cultivating the virtues and doing your
best and doing the best you can it's
helpful to know for instance that the
rain falls on the just and the unjust
alike
some religions don't recognize that
christianity does recognize that
you can be doing great things and bad
things can happen to you and it's not
necessarily god punishing you actually
can be
good for you it can be edifying it can
be sanctifying and you have to recognize
that you're not made merely for this
world that you are going to die at a
certain point no matter how well you
cultivate the virtues you're going to
die and so you're going to have a sad
end in that regard that's the that is
the consequence of sin and death
pervading the world but there is
redemption there is salvation one great
way to be happy is to recognize the fact
that your redeemer lives and and so you
you can't avoid it i know that there are
lots of uh people who are not very
religious who listen to this show and i
appreciate your patience with me because
i bring up religion a fair bit but the
reason i do it is you can't you can't
avoid religion
you're not you're not going to be able
to to think about
politics or culture or just your own
personal life without coming to
religious questions because
you come into this world you don't
really know how you got here you you
know that there's no way to get out to
live forever on this earth that no one
here gets out alive we're so befuddled
by our hopes and our joys and our loves
and all of these and sin and and pain
and what does this all mean so you're
going to have to get to some religious
answers and that will give you
and we'll give you a much better shot at
happiness and true happiness
from kemp can you explain michael why
you can't just legislate morality
why that is not a valid argument
i can although i think the burden really
should be on you because
you're the one making the claim or not
you specifically but this is what we're
responding to the claim that you can't
legislate morality so then i think my
question is why not
you're the one making this extraordinary
claim so why is it that you can't i
think you can
why can't you
well because people are that's going to
happen at the family level and that's
just from the culture and the government
has no say over you can't legislate
morality so in response to that i guess
what i would say is that i get i guess
we better get rid of murder laws right
we have to because you can't that's a
if murder is not a moral issue then what
possibly could be
and you can't you just said you can't
legislate morality murders are going to
murder all right murderers just need to
learn in their home not to murder and
they need to be taught by the culture
not to murder and so you can't have laws
against it so we'll get rid of the
murder laws right
uh no i don't think so
what about laws against tax evasion
that's a mor that's a moral issue too
different than murder but
no you can't legis if someone wants to
evade their taxes they're just they're
going to do it you know and you can law
cannot be an instructor
can it of course it can
the idea that you can't legislate
morality is just
modern day libertarian nonsense that no
one in their right mind believed until
about five minutes ago
and you shouldn't believe it either it's
just a way for politicians to avoid the
hard work of crafting laws and it's a
way to flatter the people and to allow
them to participate in their most base
desires and appetites and say oh well
you can't legislate morality so go do
whatever creepy weird thing you want to
do and go do a bunch of drugs and go
that's fine it's just a way of evading
responsibility but of course the law is
a teacher
of course it is you see this in the
bible you see this in all serious
political philosophy you see this
throughout the history of the united
states
of course when you want less of
something you pass a law against it
if it were really the case that passing
laws against bad things
has no effect on
how often they're committed or maybe
even has an inverse effect maybe you
pass a law against it and it encourages
the crime to be committed then we would
get rid of all of our laws then you
wouldn't have laws against murder or tax
evasion or anything because well no that
would be bad and that and and it won't
have any effect anyway and it might even
have a benefit no it's not
as law is against something you get less
of it generally this is true by the way
of the war on drugs as well often you'll
hear the war on drugs was a failure no
it wasn't the war on drugs was super
duper successful and drastically reduced
the number of people doing illegal drugs
from the 1970s to the 1990s so that
worked too and then we abandoned it and
then the drug use went back up and we
should probably pass tougher drug laws
too that would be that would be a rant
in in response to your question i
suppose i could put it in a pithier and
more basic way but that line it just
drives me so crazy you can't legislate
morality the only one that rivals that
line
in terms of getting my blood up is that
you you can't teach you shouldn't teach
students what to think only how to think
as though you could teach a student
how to think about mathematics without
teaching them that two plus two equals
four it's not possible my friend from
kyle michael
you've mentioned you have family in
liberal new york yes most of my family
so maybe you can help me i'm in a group
text thread with my wife and her sibling
they all work in the medical field some
of the sisters have been voicing
frustration with the coveted mandates
and rules however
my wife's brother keeps saying stuff
like it's literally just the science oh
ugh that's sad
it's sad that she
married a
gender confused individual such as that
now i would love to destroy him with
facts and logic but my wife really wants
me to not start drama in our family text
thread so what should i do sincerely
dante forgot the circle of hell
dedicated to rabid coveted liberals
good signature actually because this
dilemma reminds me that angel that fools
rush in rather where angels fear to
tread
so
your brother-in-law
is
oh okay it's not it's not the that the
sister married someone it's your wife's
brother okay that's so
all right at least a woman has not
necessarily chosen this man to be her
life partner and head of her household
because that would be really sad that
would compound the problem but what he's
saying is it's literally science and
you're a bunch of idiots if you don't
take the 17th fouchy jab or whatever you
know even though the science keeps
changing day by day often contradicting
what we said the day before
he is going to be more likely
to
interject and spout off and mouth off
and think that he is much smarter than
everybody else
often
the smartest people
in the room
are the most calm
you'll notice this in heated discussions
the people who really get angry and red
in the face and steam coming out of
their ears and screaming they usually
know less about what they're talking
about
than everyone else in the discussion and
they're getting angry because they're
getting frustrated because they can't
articulate their views so i would just
let him mouth off
a family text thread is not
a college debate
family text thread is not
owning someone with facts and logic on
youtube what's what's the purpose what's
the purpose of the thread is to keep
your family together
and to have you all interact and talk
it's not to win arguments it's not even
to convince people of true things so
let him mouth off
talk sense to a fool and he will call
you foolish
i think euripides said that
last question from brandon michael i'm
writing to you
with a question in regard to doubt in my
faith i'm a christian of roughly three
years i can't seem to shake this sort of
internal nagging doubt i listen to many
intelligent christians who are able to
rationally explain faith and present
good evidence for the reliability of the
gospels but i just can't seem to quiet
this internal doubt regardless of the
doubt i continue to pray daily read my
bible work toward becoming a stronger
christian
i wanted to know if you ever deal with
this or how you would respond yes yes
we've all had doubts i was an atheist
for 10 years
depending on your flavor of christianity
i'm not sure what denomination you are
if you're catholic or or whatnot some
are a little more skeptical than others
and so there are
certain christian friends of mine who
will say well we can never really know
for sure if god exists well you know
it's just we just got to take this leap
and we don't but you you actually can
you can know the existence of god with
certainty from the natural world by the
light of human reason
revelation plays a role as well in the
faith in a very important role but you
you can know just from the natural world
just using your own noggin that god
exists and then there will be a lot of
questions about god and the nature of
god and
the trinity and christ and christianity
and everything else but but just know
you can know the existence of god from
the natural world there are plenty of
good arguments for this you say you've
dealt with some of these arguments so
you can have confidence in that and just
because
the culture is discouraging you and just
because you don't totally understand
the nature of god who by his very
definition is incomprehensible
that that doesn't mean that you should
just uh
you know throw your faith by the wayside
or
or
worry unnecessarily there's a great
story about saint augustine that saint
augustine was writing about the trinity
and it's a legend of course but he's
writing about the trinity walks up he
sees a kid
using a clam shell and putting water
into a little hole from the ocean
augustine says what are you doing and
the kid says oh i'm gonna fill the whole
ocean into this hole and augustine says
you can't do that you can't fit the
ocean in that hole and then the boy
miraculously is transformed into an
angel and he says yeah neither can you
fit the trinity into your little head
saint augustine and this legend though
it is has a lot of
a lot of
truth to it
because of course god is by nature if
god were
totally comprehensible by you he would
not be god so god does exist you can
trust that
just as you might struggle to understand
some aspect of i don't know calculus how
much more complicated the divine logic
of the universe so persist keep at it
keep praying don't be discouraged don't
let the devil get you down i'm michael
knowles it's the michael knowles show
see you monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright dailywire 2022. hey
everybody this is andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin